a lot of fans out there are really
hoping for a reconciliation with Jared
oh yeah what do you have to say about
that
Oh time will only tell right are you
open to that
sure performer bachelor star Ashley Iook
an Eddie the time is finally right
the 30-year old reality star revealed
she and fellow bachelor in paradise
co-star Jared Haven are officially
dating the person I wanted to be with
most was right in front of my eyes
the couple candidly told their story on
Ashley's web series the story of us from
the moment they first heard about one
another to their very first kiss I said
I there's one more thing I forgot to
give you definitely like hesitated for a
second really yeah and then I just went
for it and then and then we kissed to
seal the deal Jared professed his
feelings for Ashley in a heartfelt
handwritten letter all I know is that
I'm happier when I'm with you and now
their relationship is stronger than ever
he tells me every day that he's the
luckiest man alive and I but my my dad
does my mom that after 40 years
[Music]
[Applause]
you